[Music]
hi I'm best-selling novelist Andrew
Clavin and I'm here to talk to you about
Benghazi how'd you get into my house I
climbed in through a window on September
11th 2012 our consulate in Benghazi
Libya was attacked and four Americans
including our ambassador were killed I'm
not comfortable with this I can
understand that even though the
president and the Secretary of State
knew this was a terrorist attack they
told the public it was a spontaneous
demonstration inspired by an anti
Mohammed video I know this story well
you know there are hearings going on in
Congress right now you can probably look
on your CNN app and find out all about
it
yeah I'm not singing about it but that's
Charles Ramsey the hero
he is isn't he you know the funny thing
is is even though this was a major story
a scandal that cost for American lives
active incompetence about the highest
level of government that press pretty
much covered this up to make sure that
Barack Obama would get elected that
sounds like doesn't it that's kind of
sad but it is I'll bet if you went on a
college campus and asked just a random
selection of people I'll bet none of
them would have heard about Benghazi
what's been your reaction to Benghazi
unfolding what's been your reaction to
Benghazi this week ever since this
tragedy occurred the media and the
administration have been working in
tandem to keep information about it from
the American public
in fact when the Secretary of State was
questioned in front of Congress
she said what difference does it make
how these Americans died those words
actually came out of the mouth of
Hillary Clinton
[Music]